what do you think
about bitcoin what do you think it is a
response to what are the growing
problems of the fiat system
what is this moment in human history
that is full of challenges that bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies trying to overcome
i don't think bitcoin
was devised by satoshi
whoever he was
for fear of
a breakdown of the fiat currencies
if it was it was a very far-sighted
enterprise because certainly in 2008
when the first bitcoin paper appeared it
wasn't very likely that
a wave of inflation was coming if
anything
there was more reason to fear deflation
at that point i think
it would be more accurate to say
that with the advent of the internet
there was a need for a means of payment
native to the internet
typing your credit card number into a
random website it's not the way
to pay for things on the internet
and i'd rather think of bitcoin as the
first iteration the first attempt to
solve the problem of how do we pay for
things in what we must learn to call the
metaverse but
let's just call it the internet for old
times sake
and ever since that initial uh
innovation the realization that you
could use computing power and
cryptography to create
peer-to-peer payments without third
party verification
a revolution has been gathering momentum
that poses a very profound threat to the
existing legacy system of banks and and
fiat currencies
most money in the world today is made by
banks not central banks banks
that's what most money is it's entries
in bank accounts
and
what bitcoin represents is an
alternative mode of payment that really
ought to render banks obsolete
i think this financial revolution has
got past the point at which it can be
killed it was vulnerable in the early
years
but it now has sufficient adoption
and has generated sufficient additional
layers i mean ethereum was in many ways
the more important innovation because
you can build a whole
system of of payments and ultimately
smart contracts on top of ether i think
we've now reached the point that it's
pretty hard to imagine it all being
killed
and it's just survived an amazing thing
which was the chinese shutting down
mining and shutting down everything and
still here we are
uh in fact crypto's
thriving
what we don't know is how much damage
ill-judged regulatory interventions are
going to do to this financial revolution
left to its own devices i think
decentralized finance provides
the native
monitoring financial system for the
internet
and the more time we spend in the
metaverse the more use we will make of
it the next things that will happen i
think will be that
tokens in game spaces like roblox will
become fungible
as my nine-year-old spends a lot more
time playing on
computer games than i ever did i can see
that entertainment
is becoming
a game driven phenomenon and in the game
space
you need skins for your avatar
the economics of the internet
it's evolving very fast and in parallel
you can see this payments revolution
happening i think that all
that all goes naturally very well and
generates an enormous amount of wealth
in the process
the the problem is
there are people in washington with an
overwhelming urge to intervene and
disrupt this evolutionary uh process
partly i think
out of a muddled sense that there must
be a lot of nefarious things going on
if we don't step in many more will go on
this i think greatly exaggerates how
much criminal activity is in fact going
on in the space
but there's also the vested interests at
work
it was odd to me
maybe not odd
perhaps it wasn't surprising but the
bank for international settlements
earlier this year published
a report
uh one chapter of which said this must
all go let's all stop
it's all got to be shut down
and it's going to be replaced by central
bank digital currency
and martin wolf in the financial times
read this and said i agree with this and
one suddenly realized that the the banks
are clever they had they'd achieved the
intellectual counter-attack
uh
with
almost no fingerprints on the weapon
i think central bank digital currency is
a terrible idea
i can't imagine why we would want to
copy a chinese model that essentially
takes all transactions and puts them
directly under the surveillance of a
central government institution but
that suddenly is a
serious counter proposal
so on the one side we have a relatively
decentralized
technologically
innovative internet native system of
payments that has the possibility to
evolve to produce a full set of
of smart contracts
reducing enormously the transaction
costs that we currently encounter in the
financial world because it gets rid of
all those middlemen who take their cut
every time you take out a mortgage or
whatever it is that's one
alternative on the other side we have a
highly centralized system in which
transactions will by default be under
the surveillance of the central bank
seems like an easy choice to me but hey
i have this thing about personal liberty
so that's where we are i don't think
that the regulators can can kill uh
web 3 i think we're supposed to call it
web 3 because crypto is now an
obsolescent term they can't kill it but
they can definitely make it difficult
and
throw a lot of sand into the machine
and i think worst of all they can spoil
the evolutionary story by
by creating central bank digital
currency that i don't think we really
need or
we certainly don't need it in the
chinese form
so do you think bitcoin
has a strong chance to take over the
world so
become the primary you mentioned the
three things that make money money
that become the primary methodology by
which we store wealth we exchange
no
no i think what bitcoin is
this was a phrase that i i got from my
friend matt mclennan first eagle an
option on digital gold so it's the gold
of the system
but currently it behaves like an option
that's why it's quite volatile because
we don't really know if this
brave new world of
crypto is gonna work
but if it does work then bitcoin is the
gold because of the finite supply
what role
we need gold to play in the metaverse
isn't quite
clear i love that you're using the term
metaverse this is great well i i just
like the metaversity as a kind of yeah
as the antithesis of what we're trying
to do in in austin but
i love it but can you imagine i'm using
it sarcastically i come from glasgow
where all novel words have to be used
sarcastically so the metaverse sarcastic
but see the beauty about humor and
sarcasm is that
the joke becomes reality i mean it's
like using the word big bang to describe
the origins of the universe it becomes
like that
it will after a while it's in the
textbooks yeah and nobody's laughing
yeah well that's exactly right so sticky
yeah
um i'm on the side of humor but it is a
it is a dangerous activity these days
anyway i think bitcoin is is the option
of digital gold
the
the role it plays is probably
not so much store of value right now
it's just nicely not very correlated
asset in your portfolio when i updated
the ascent of money which was in 2018 10
years after it came out
i wrote a new chapter in which i said
bitcoin which had just sold off after
its 2017 bubble will rise again through
adoption
because if every millionaire in the
world
has point two percent of his or her
wealth in bitcoin the price should be
fifteen thousand dollars if it's one
percent it's 75 000
and it might not even stay at one
percent because i mean look at its
recent performance if you
if your exposure to stocks global stocks
have been hedged with a significant uh
crypto holding you would have aced the
last few months
so i think the non-correlation
[Music]
property is very very important in
driving
adoption and the volatility also drives
adoption if you're a sophisticated
investor uh so i think the adoption
drives uh
uh bitcoin up
because it's the option of digital gold
but it's also just this nicely not very
correlated asset that you want to hold
in in a world where the hell i mean the
bank central bank is going to tighten
we've come through this massively
disruptive episode of the pandemic
public debt soared money printing soared
you could hang around with your bonds
and wait for the euthanasia of the
rontier you can hang on to your tech
stocks and just hope there isn't a
massive correction or dot dot dot well
and
it seems like a fairly obvious strategy
to make sure that you have at least some
crypto
for the coming year
given what we likely have to face
i think what's really interesting is
that on top of ethereum
a more elaborate
financial system is being built
stable coins are the interesting
puzzle
for me
because we need off ramps
ultimately you and i have to pay taxes
in us dollars
and
there's no getting away from that
the irs is going to let us hold crypto
as long as we pay our taxes and the only
question in my mind is what's the
optimal off-ramp
to make those taxes make those tax
payments
probably it shouldn't be a currency
invented by facebook never struck me as
the best solution to this problem
maybe it's some kind of fed coin
uh or maybe one of the the existing
algorithmic stable coins does the job
but we clearly need some stable off-ramp
so you don't think it's possible for the
irs within the next decade to be
accepting bitcoin as tax payments
i doubt that
having dealt with the irs now since when
did i first come here 2002
it's hard to think of an institution
less likely to
leap into the
21st century when it comes to to
payments no i think i think we'll we'll
be
we'll be tolerated
crypto world will be tolerated as long
as we pay our taxes that's the and it's
important that we're already at that
point
and then the next question becomes well
does gary gensler define everything as a
security and do we then have to go
through
endless regulatory contortions to
satisfy the sec
there's a whole bunch of of
uncertainties that the administrative
state excels at creating because you
know that's just how that's how the
administrative state works you'll do
something new hmm
i'll decide whether that's a security
but don't expect me to define it for you
i'll decide in an arbitrary way and then
you'll owe me money so all of this is
going to be very annoying and you know
for people who are trying to run
uh exchanges or uh innovate in the space
these these regulations will be annoying
but the problem with fintech is it's
it's different from tech broadly defined
you know when tech got into e-commerce
with amazon when it got into social
networking with facebook
there wasn't a huge regulatory jungle to
navigate
but welcome to the world of finance
which has always been
a jungle of regulation because the
regulation is is there to
you know basically entrench the
incumbents that's what it's for
so
it'll be a much tougher fight than the
fights we've we've seen over
other aspects of the tech revolution
because because the incumbents are are
there and they see
the threat
and in the end
satoshi said it very explicitly it's
peer-to-peer payment without third party
verification and all the third parties
are going wait what
we're the third parties
so there is a connection between power
and money
you've mentioned world war one
from the perspective of money so
power
money
war
authoritarian regimes
from the perspective of money do you
have hope that cryptocurrency can help
resist war can help
resist the negative effects of
authoritarian regimes
or is that a silly hope
wars
happen because the people
who have the power to command armed
forces
miscalculate
that's generally what happens
and we will have a big war in the near
future if
both the chinese government and the us
government miscalculates
and they unleash lethal lethal force on
one another and there's nothing that any
financial institution can do to stop
that
any more than the rothschilds
rothschilds could stop world war one
and they were then the biggest bank in
the world by far with massive
international financial influence
so let's accept that war is is in a
different domain
war
would impact the financial world
massively if it were a war between the
united states and china because
there's still a huge
china trade on
wall street is long china
europe is long china
so the conflict that i could foresee in
the future is one that's highly
financially disruptive
where does crypto fit in
crypto's obvious
utility in the short run
is as a store of
wealth of transferable wealth for people
who live
in dangerous places with
failing not just failing money but
failing rule of law
that's why in latin america there's so
much interest in crypto because latin
americans have a lot of monetary history
to look back on and not much of it is
good
so i think that the short run
problem that crypto solves
is and this goes back to the the digital
gold point
if you are in a dangerous place with
weak rule of law and weak property
rights
here is a new and better way to have
portable wealth
i think the next
question to ask is
would you want to be long crypto
in the event of world war iii
what's interesting about that question
is that world war iii would likely have
a significant cyber dimension to it
and i don't want to be 100 in crypto if
they crash the internet
which between them china and russia
might be able to do
that's a fascinating question whether
you want to be holding physical gold or
digital gold in the event of world war
three the smart person who studied
history definitely wants better both
and
so let's imagine world war iii has a
very very severe cyber component to it
with high levels of disruption
yeah you'd be glad of the old the old
shiny stuff at that point so
diversification still seems like the
most important
truth of a financial history
and and what is crypto it's just this
wonderful new source of diversification
but you'd be nuts to be a 100 in bitcoin
i mean i i have some friends who are
probably quite close to that close to
100
admire the i admire the bowls of steel
you